Rishi capti v hello Evan hello Steven
beyond money what should an entrepreneur
look for when choosing the ideal
investor thank you so I'd say definitely
in the bootstrapping phase Evan I'd say
not only the investable so extend this
to sort of employees I love to see
companies getting partners employees
investors even suppliers to teaching
supplies can't put skin in the game of
following your dream believing in your
story and making your business a success
so that sort of things I look for
certainly from an investor and this
translates to our employees as well
someone who's really committed on the
idea who gets the story gets the idea
that you've got with a service business
product business and then more
importantly can add value to the growth
of your business so particularly as an
angel investor i sat on a few of the
boards and I chaired a couple of the
boards when we started the businesses
and I gave a lot of time to coach and
mentor the chief executive for these
businesses and even through to the phase
when they are beyond through a growth
capital as an advisor and a coach to
those guys over to yell at 32 years
experience in the industry and there's a
lot of guys like me out there who have
had very successful careers and they can
be really good mentors and they're also
non-invasive were you get into the world
of VCS little restrictive covenants they
want to put warrants both so they've got
a seat around the board table and they
can be quite invasive in terms of you
having freedom to run your company and
this year your dreams so I'd look for
someone with experience they've got time
they've got they got real appetite for
your story and support you where your
business and and therefore connectors a
tremendous coach and mentor as well as
the money they can provide at key stages
and if it works most of these angel
investors I've been involved in go
through the distance and multiple
so they go through the whole journey
with the firm's from the companies as
they scale and grow them through their
success I love it uh in the VC world
here we call the dumb money smart money
I don't the same thing in the UK but
dumb money is just money and you you
really want that as a last resort
because you want somebody word smart
money they're providing contacts at
providing information training mentoring
open up doors for you help you get
clients help you get media whatever it
is that you need to help grow the
business you want somebody who is
obviously yes passionate about where
you're going somebody you feel you can
work with but somebody who brings
something extra beyond it right whether
those contacts customers opening some
kind of door for you alongside the
mentoring and training that's what you
really want to look for and I would
honestly hold out until you find that
right person if that's your goal then
just to accept the first check that
comes in the door because you can't you
can't easily get rid of investors that
that's a that's a long-term decision
you're making right there so just like
when you get married you want to make
sure that you're making the right
decision start yeah I'm just to add just
one of the firm's of his chief executive
of actually a couple of times I've got a
customer to come on the board and be a
mentor for me and later an investor so I
kind of think this is a great time if
you're bootstrapping your business to
think outside the box who would you like
around the table giving you all business
advice that's got a tremendous insight
into the market the future the product
innovation you're trying to lead that
could give you invaluable advice and
give you a real sanity check so I aren't
always back smart money i'm always back
people who got skin in the game and who
got a strong commitment to you and your
business growing be a successful